i had so much fun i think i nailed it as
far as um my my personality my stage
presence and the best part about it i
had fun um it was bittersweet knowing
that this would be my last time
performing my set on the stage and to
have steady ovations for both of my
songs for my coaches was just such a
genuine heartwarming feeling
so what was words of advice that your
coach gave you before you went up there
to actually do this because now you have
a chance of winning this all
well the best advice he gave me was
honestly just connect with the song
emotionally make the audience feel what
you're you're feeling and um that kind
of has stuck with me ever since he told
me that and every time i step on that
stage i just want to make sure that i'm
delivering where i can touch hearts no
matter what i'm singing
that makes a lot of sense well
congratulations i can't wait to see
what's going to happen tomorrow thank
you so much bobby
all right hello jessica
congratulations on making it to the
finale after the save last week i want
to find out when you what do you think
you learned the most about yourself
during this time in the competition
the one thing that i can learn about
myself is i have such a strong backbone
um and i'm a fighter i bounce back like
nothing ever happened um and people
don't know behind the scenes i'm i'm
human so i have my moments too but um
it's what matters what happens after
that and i feel like um i broke through
both of those moments and
i conquered and i came to to win those
many battles that that have you know
that were
taunting me and um i feel like that's
something i learned about myself that
i'm a fighter
thank you good luck to you
thank you so much
now that the season is almost over when
you look back on this time is there a
particular moment that stood out to you
as just like either it was a really fun
moment or sort of you looked at it and
you were like oh i can't believe i did
that
um i would go back to the blind
auditions and we still joke about it
today actually carson joked about it
tonight he said uh i in the in the in
the very beginning blonde i was i'm a
security guard and i made a comment to
the coaches in some of the audience i
was like oh so i'll lock you up
and uh till this day they still joke
about it and carson said it again
tonight and we just use it as like a
joke and so i was like well so i'll lock
you up so that you can vote for me
but um yeah that's probably the most
iconic funny moment it shows the side of
my personality um that i'm not always
serious i love to have fun and i like to
crack jokes
jersey just tell me what the whole
atmosphere of tonight was like i mean
did you almost feel like you were in
wonderland i mean thinking about where
you were a year ago tonight
and where you are tonight
um while the atmosphere tonight the
audience the love oh my goodness after
performing both of my songs even
beforehand they were just so excited and
just so so loving and kind um but
tonight was just a magical moment
honestly we'll go down in history as one
of the best nights of my life regardless
of what happens tomorrow i had fun i
went in and i was i was myself um and i
felt like i delivered the very best i
knew how and um yeah that's that
what if carson calls your name is the
winner
i'm gonna cry i'm gonna probably fall to
my knees and cry i am going to be so
thankful
um emotional rollercoaster will be tears
all running down my face um it would
definitely be a moment um in a
life-changing life-changing moment for
me and my family for the rest of my life
thanks jeshika good luck to you
thank you mark
i know it's probably hard to see past
you know tomorrow night but what is like
the next
step for you like what's the next thing
that you want to go out there and
accomplish i mean hopefully it's winning
the voice but what do you see for your
career post this
um honestly i want to continue to be an
artist you know and make music um you
know staying really relevant in the the
the hollywood world um really heavy and
just make sure that i'm you know doing
my very best work to bring um good
content and you know stuff to the to the
world and my my biggest thing is really
just making more music putting out music
as soon as possible um inspirational
music gospel music um because the world
needs that and if i can be a beacon of
light for for that i i will definitely
do that so with being on stage and and
having all these things happen this
great production how was that emotion
with all that because again it's so big
it is so now and this is like like every
person's dream like i want a horn
section in a band
and dolphins and i want somebody flying
from the sky you've got all that right
now so how amazing was that feeling
oh my god it's so amazing all of the
hands that go to work for you behind the
scenes i'm just so incredibly thankful
for all the people who make the props
you know bringing all these dancers and
all these you know violinists and it's
just it's so amazing to know that they
do all of this work for you and um and
i'm pretty sure it's not cheap so um
they invest in you very well and it's
really good to know that people you know
they're invested in your gift they want
the best for you they want you to look
the best to sound the best um and i'm
just so grateful for that i'm truly
gonna miss the people who work behind
the scenes um it's bittersweet it was a
beautiful sweet moment tonight but um
all in all it's it was beautiful
no it definitely was it's it's got to be
the cool feeling i know you guys have
cheese i'm like this is amazing
this is for me
you're saying so many great songs this
season were there a couple songs you
wanted to sing this season you just
didn't have a chance to
i'm sorry you said it again you kind of
breaking up i said were there a couple
of songs you wanted to sing this season
that you just never got a chance
yes there was there were some chaka khan
songs that i actually wanted to sing uh
paris song one of them tonight
and then also there was a melody still
lingers on that was a fun song um there
were a lot of songs i think they wanted
me to stay away from the aretha and the
shocker and um i was okay with that
because i'm super open anyways and i
wanted to do every genre so i feel like
anything they do at me they're like oh
yeah she's got it and um you know i
wanted to just be flexible i feel like
that's that that works and it pays off
and it makes you stand out so i don't
want to be put in a box
thank you
so then now that you have you look past
tomorrow and has figured out like you
know what a
the single or what what an album of
yours would sound like as far as like
you know i really want to do this and
this is the this is the opportunity that
i have
yes absolutely i actually have a
producer already my manager before i
even left for the voice i was already
working on an album um that is gospel
music contemporary christian gospel
music um so i'm so excited to release
some of that whenever i can i know we
have contracts and stuff here and
they'll let us know what release dates
when we can release those things but
yeah that is definitely in the works um
i definitely want to make sure that i
take a vacation before i do anything i
need a mental break this is a lot um
like go to hawaii or something and then
after that i definitely want to get back
to work maybe do some tours and shows
and you know whatever else scott has in
in the lane for me i'll just you know
follow that lady
so instead of going disneyland you're
gonna go hawaii got it
i would love to go to hawaii i would
love to go to disneyland too like i am
not biased i would go to every land
honestly any land i just need to get on
a land where it's just green and water
and peace
i understand
we can't wait
thank you
you